it's been about four months since apple
revealed the iphone 13 lineup at their
september event and ever since i got my
hands on the 13 pro max i've been using
it every single day and i've gotta say
that i've never been as satisfied with
an iphone as i am right now with this
one so in this four month review i'm
gonna do something completely different
with the goal of helping you decide if
it's still worth upgrading to one of the
iphone 13 pro models or simply holding
off for the iphone 14 pro which has the
chance of coming with features like a
pill-shaped cutout instead of the notch
and maybe even a usb-c port like i
talked about in a previous video which
you should definitely check out but with
all that said the way i'm gonna do this
review is by making a list of every
single update or upgrade that came with
the 13 pro max and i'm gonna be sharing
my thoughts on which features actually
matter to me after 4 months of use with
the best features being saved for last
so let's get right into it first up we
have the changes that matter to me the
least like apple selling a one terabyte
iphone model which i definitely don't
need and things like the dual e sim
feature which don't matter to me since i
don't need more than one cellular line
there's also the new sierra blue color
which i really dislike so i ended up
going with graphite and i covered it up
with a leather skin from nomad which has
been incredibly impressive and resilient
and no they're not sponsoring this video
but getting back into the real new
features we have one that really didn't
matter to me at all and that's
photographic styles which allows you to
apply a pre-filter to all of your photos
but i honestly haven't touched this once
since my original review because i
personally like the default color
profile coming from the 13 pro so i
don't really need this feature after
that we have the new pro res recording
format and to me this is still a gimmick
because i don't really shoot videos with
my iphone with the intention of them
going into a professional video or
anything like that and since the file
size is absolutely massive i decided
that it's not even worth it for me to
enable that format for the everyday
stuff that i record like videos of my
kid now another upgrade we got this year
that apple didn't really talk about was
the fact that the iphone 13 pro max can
now accept up to 27 watts of charging
power so because of that i went ahead
and ordered an anchor 30 watt charger
just so i don't feel like i'm missing
out on potentially faster charging speed
but to be honest because of the
incredible battery life of this phone
which i'm gonna get to in just a couple
of minutes i haven't really been using
that adapter that much however when i
need to top up the battery quickly i'm
constantly blown away by how fast it
charges up compared to how long it used
to take a couple of years ago so this
new faster charging can definitely be
useful and now talking a little bit
about the cameras the selfie camera this
year got a small upgrade with some of
the features the rear camera gets like
prores recording but the one that i've
actually noticed is the jump up to smart
hdr4 which gives it a very noticeable
improvement in terms of high dynamic
range performance so now you're much
less likely to have blown out clouds in
the background which is a small but
helpful improvement and i also noticed
that sun flaring isn't nearly as bad of
a problem as it was last year so that's
very nice now one new feature that i
thought was going to be a massive game
changer is the new cinematic video
recording mode so i tested it out a few
times and i got some really cool looking
shots like this one of my wife and son
walking around downtown and i also
noticed that the stabilization is
absolutely incredible making it look
like you're holding a gimbal but
unfortunately it still has issues with
making it look natural since the blur
edging messes up sometimes and that
totally ruins the feel so in my opinion
this is going to be one of those
features that apple has to fine-tune
over the next few years but is just not
ready right now and because it's limited
to just 1080p quality i just can't get
myself to use it because i know that
this phone is capable of shooting in 4k
so i feel like i'm missing out in terms
of quality when i use cinematic video
mode next up we have the new macro mode
which was very impressive and exciting
when apple revealed it but i just
haven't been using it that much now
initially it was really messed up and
buggy because it worked automatically
and you couldn't control the lens that
it was switching to but apple quickly
fixed that issue and has added a button
for macro mode and it works like a charm
and what i really like about it is that
you can get some really cool shots like
this one of a toy car with a unique wide
angle perspective but still it's
sometimes hard to get the focus right if
you're too close but it can really help
you see details like the stamp on the
inside of this ring and for scenarios
like that this feature is awesome and
priceless now moving on to the next
feature the 13 pro now lets you manually
adjust the brightness up to a thousand
nits instead of last year's 800 which
has been very convenient for me in
situations where i want the display as
bright as possible since i don't like
using auto brightness and in terms of
the chipset this year's iphones also
come with the new a15 bionic chip with
the pro models getting the faster five
core gpu and while i haven't really
noticed a difference in snappiness
directly from the performance
improvement alone i've been testing out
some games and i've been really
impressed by the performance like for
example getting a solid 120 fps in games
like league of legends wild rift with no
hiccups at all and for other games that
are limited to 60 hertz i discovered
that you can enable low power mode and
still get perfect 60fps while saving an
impressive amount of battery life
compared to not having it on making it
the perfect mode for gaming and it's
only possible because of the high amount
of raw horsepower and efficiency with
the a15 channel and with that said let's
finally get into the main camera which
was upgraded with a better sensor and an
f 1.5 aperture lens to let in quite a
bit more light the level of noise
visible in photos is very very low
especially in dimmer situations and it's
just so much better than it was before
and in terms of daylight shots i've
never been so happy with photos coming
off of an iphone with them all being
super super sharp and in terms of
portrait mode using the main lens
everything looks absolutely amazing
especially with the really nice gradual
blur depth range as something gets
further away from the subject and i've
noticed that the camera can capture so
much color data like the natural sunset
hour glow with incredibly realistic
bokeh and even at night the night mode
portraits have been refined compared to
last year and they turn out amazing and
by far the biggest difference at night
is that the 13 pro match can perfectly
reproduce the natural glow and color
from neon lights which no other phone
can get right so yeah the camera
performance including the hardware and
the software has never been better and i
wouldn't choose any other phone's camera
over this one but an even bigger deal
that really matters to me is that this
year the ultrawide camera has been
upgraded with an f 1.8 aperture lens
compared to f 2.4 last year so it lets
in a ton more light and this led to a
massive difference in quality making it
actually usable now for lower light
situations and much more detail for
video recording as well so because of
all of this i'm using the ultra wide
lens much more often now compared to
last year with the 12 pro max so i'm
very happy about this ultrawide lens and
even better the new upgraded 3x optical
zoom lens is so much better than last
year's 2.5 x lens on the 12 pro max
which suffered from lots of issues with
noise so for the same reasons i hardly
ever used the telephoto lens last year
but now it looks very good and deals
with low light much better and on top of
that the new 77 millimeter focal length
is perfect for portrait photos making
them look closer to professional
portraits than ever before and i've got
to say that portrait mode with this lens
looks amazing with apple finally tuning
it perfectly while giving the background
a very natural blur including bokeh that
looks better than i've ever seen before
so overall i've never been more happy
with the camera performance and when it
comes to 4k video recording across any
of the lenses it's literally the best in
the business now moving on we have the
speaker quality upgrade with the
speakers having noticeably more volume
compared to last year which is very
important to me since i like to turn on
youtube videos while in the shower in
other situations and i no longer have
any issues with hearing what was said
but on the other hand the quality has
also received a huge improvement as well
with sharper highs and better dynamic
range between all of the frequencies and
this is really important to me since
there are so many use cases where i
simply use the built-in speakers instead
of reaching for my earpods and now
finishing off with the last three major
features that matter the most to me
after four months we have the much
improved heat management with the iphone
12 from max the display with dim and
various situations like just being on
the max a wireless charger just being
out in the sun while using apps just
turning the brightness all the way up to
the max and especially while gaming but
this year i've only witnessed the
display dim a couple of times during the
past four months compared to literally a
daily basis with the 12 pro max which
was extremely annoying and even if the
display does dim it usually only went
down to around 80 percent of the maximum
brightness compared to as low as 40
percent with the 12 which was insanely
dark so i'm very happy that apple was
able to fix this issue with the 13 pro
max and now for the second most
important feature we have the battery
life which has been absolutely
incredible and even mind-blowing at
times for the first time ever i no
longer have to even think about my
battery life because it's just so good
and it can literally last a day and a
half with regular use which never used
to happen before with any other iphone
and this matters to me so much because
it gives me a sense of freedom knowing
that i can play games at any time i want
without worrying about the battery life
at all in fact i completely stopped
charging my 13 pro max at night which
used to be something i had to do no
matter what with previous iphones to
make sure that it would last through the
next day nowadays it mostly just stays
topped up by using my car's mac safe
vent mount charger while driving and
using my convenient mac safe stand at
work with me only really having to
resort to wired cable charging on the
weekends and this level of battery life
is surprising coming from the 12 pro max
since that had decent battery life so i
couldn't imagine how it would feel
coming from an older or smaller iphone
to this one and now finally we have the
number one new feature that matters to
me the most and that is unsurprisingly
the 120hz pro motion refresh rate
feature which is exclusive to the pro
models for many years the chips have
gotten more and more powerful but you'd
never notice that big of a difference in
terms of snappiness because the refresh
rate of the iphone has always stuck to
60 hertz but now this 13 pro max feels
more snappy than any iphone i've ever
had solely because of once when he hurts
promotion especially for scrolling
through content like twitter and the
reason i know it matters to me so much
is because when someone asked me for
some help with their settings or some
kind of feature on their older 60hz
iphone the display looks so stuttery and
choppy that for a slight moment i think
that it might be broken or it might have
some kind of display issue before i
remember that it's actually a 60hz
display compared to 120 on the 13 pro
max and of course this has also been
very nice for things like gaming at
perfect 120fps and games like league of
legends making everything incredibly
smooth but my favorite thing of all is
apple's implementation of 120 hertz
using promotion which automatically
tunes the refresh rate down on the fly
to save battery life and while it's not
perfect all the time it's definitely
worth it and it's my absolute favorite
feature of the 13 pro max so there you
guys go hopefully you enjoyed my four
month review and if you did go ahead and
comment your thoughts down below and
definitely click the circle about to
subscribe for more videos like this one
and check out one of those two right
over there thanks for watching and i'll
see you in the next video
[Music]
you